there's nothing you can't accomplish in
life with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
do the work there is another level the
only reason you keep seeing there isn't
as you feel so exhausted about where you
are
I should think well I feel fair about
this and therefore I shouldn't do it
it's normal to be to feel fair like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong you shouldn't feel fair
what's that belief nation is heaven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world now I started to believe
life series to once a week tackle a
different topic in personal development
so to help you live your best believe
live today we're going to learn 10
reasons why people fail enjoy
[Music]
reason number one they never try in the
first place
with Mark Zuckerberg in a world that's
changing so quickly the biggest risk you
can take is not taking any risk and I
really think that that's true
right a lot of people I think think that
you know whatever it comes to whatever
you get yourself into a position where
you have to make some some big shift and
direction or do something you know there
are always people are going to point to
the downside risks of that decision and
locally there may be right right I mean
if for any given decision that you're
gonna make there's upside and downside
but in aggregate if you are stagnant and
you don't make those changes then then I
think you're guaranteed to fail right
and not not catch up so to some degree I
think it's really right that over time
the biggest risk that you can take is to
not take any risks reason number two
they are lazy with mark human most
people do a lot of talking and most
people don't put in the effort there's
nothing you can't accomplish in life
with the right amount of work the
challenge is you know are you willing to
do the work and the reality is most
people aren't but that's the opportunity
right is I mean it's like people you
know at school most people are lazy
right they they just they barely get
through it and and so that creates
opportunity I tell my kids that a if
they want something they're gonna have
to earn it
yeah and B if they don't work hard
enough to earn it I'm going to sell them
off as medical experiments that's the
line in our house right
you need money okay we'll set you off as
a medical experiment we can get you
money that way I'll give blood dad I'm
seven I don't care
reason number three they fear failure
with Mel Robbins and I think everybody
has fear all wrong people have so many
theories about fear they talk about oh
I'm afraid of success know I'm afraid of
failure
I'm afraid of intimacy I'm afraid of
heights I'm afraid of this I'm afraid of
that I'm afraid of the other thing
there's actually only two fears only two
and if you're in sales which you are or
even if you're not life is about
persuading people life is about
influencing people and fear is the
invisible force that will make you
ineffective at that it will stop you now
I love JK Rollins as an example I mean
we all know the Harry Potter series but
what a lot of people don't know about
her she talks a lot about fear she
struggled with major depression do you
know she was unemployed and she wrote
the original idea for Harry Potter on a
napkin while she was on state benefits
she was then rejected by 12 publishing
houses and this by the way was after she
was divorced bankrupt and a single mom
of a kid pushed herself pushed herself
pushed herself she talks a lot about
fear and about failure well you know we
know the moral of the story she just
kept going of course she was afraid but
she had the good kind of fear not the
bad kind of fear reason number four they
lacked planning with Daymond - a
business plan got a lot of business that
doesn't exist is a lot because you can't
you can't say like who do your facts
based on because it hasn't had
you can't really determine who's going
by what and how much this cost cell you
can't say I'm gonna make a million this
year this is not gonna be your ass you
know what what I'll do was put together
without it's like a script I'll put
together how we make the goods I'm gonna
market the goods how much this cost to
buy the goods we have with my margin and
then when I'm gonna sell it and then how
much I'm gonna put back into the
business and how much I'm gonna put in
my part you know is that kind of thing
you know I write things that like if you
look look one put that on the wall right
there right this is a serial you see a
piece of paper well I don't want it
that's it I got to do you know I like to
put things on the wall I can't even know
what I've got to do I need to look at it
and to cross it out I don't consider
that a business plan per se or but I
have a plan you know I'm saying like I
have a plan plus you want other people
to understand the plan because you can't
do anything on your own so you want to
be able to articulate it to them away
they understand and that they can look
back because I've talked quick and like
you said a lot of times I say [ __ ] you
like I didn't understand that I'm you
later yeah you know so you want to have
something someone they keep looking at
and they can see you crossing it off and
then they can kind of get it by
absorbing all you know by about watching
what you're doing
reason number five they don't learn and
adapt fast enough with Jeff Bezos if you
want to be an inventor of any kind of
venting a new you know a new service
offering for customers or a new product
or anything
the being an inventor requires because
the world is so complicated you have to
be a domain expert I mean in a way even
if even if you're not at the beginning
you have to learn learn learn learn
learn enough so to become a domain
expert but the danger is once you've
become a domain expert you can be
trapped by that knowledge and so
inventors have this paradoxical ability
to have that you know 10,000 hours of
practice and be a real domain expert and
have that beginner's mind have that that
look at it freshly
even though they know so much about the
domain and that's the key to inventing
you have to have both and I think that
is intentional I think all of us have
that inside of us and we could all do it
but you have to be intentional
you have to say yeah I am gonna become
an expert and I'm gonna keep my
beginner's mind recent number six they
lack self-discipline with Joe Rogan well
I think the one thing that discipline
definitely does help you with is it
helps you get things done and when you
get things done when you you actually do
things you you you have more success if
you have more success sometimes a big
part of success is just not being lazy
and just doing it yeah just get that's
like 90% of it is just showing up get
there and start working like you're not
gonna feel perfect every day if I felt
if I only worked out when I felt good
I'd be a fat because there's a lot of
days I don't want to do it if it's
pretty much the same with everybody that
if that actually gets good at something
that you you get there's got to be those
days you push through and they're them
they're probably gonna be more numerous
than the days you don't and so the
benefit of discipline in my eyes has
always been that through discipline I
get things done I always tell me I would
say that I'm like the most lazy
disciplined person I know because I
don't want to do it yeah but I always do
reason number seven they make excuses
with Grant Cardone hey I was broke you
understand I was broke when I was 25
dead broke I'm not talking about
financially broke let me tell you
something no I didn't have any money in
my pocket I didn't have any credit cards
nobody would give me credit okay didn't
have a driver's license okay 1970 Ford
Maverick had a 1970 Ford Maverick no air
no heat no door handles the freakin
floor was rusted okay I lived in a 275
square foot apartment maybe 300 square
feet if he counted a little stead out in
the front
front door 275 a month and I was late
almost every month so don't tell me
about your money problems man okay don't
tell me about where you were born don't
tell me about your bad brakes don't tell
me about what your daddy did or your
uncle felt you up or something just some
kind of weird thing too you know I'll
ruin your head or your sister abused you
or whatever okay look we all got
problems you got to fix your problems
now you got to get your money right so
25 years old I'm like I'm getting my
money right I'm done no more excuses no
more crybaby no more blame I'm getting
my freaking money right reason number
eight they're resistant to feedback with
Mel Gibson I remember it was three hours
and 15 minutes of one stage and I would
had this great editor who I worked with
again called Steve rosenbloom and
Rosenblum and I was sitting there
scratching our heads bigger in how do we
get a half hour out of this and we
couldn't figure it out because we were
so close to it and it took a studio head
to come in and give us a general note
that was Sherry Lansing she gives us
this general note and we're like we look
at her and we look at each other's and
what would she know how did she get this
job you know in 24 hours later we're
going she's right she's first to do it
yeah but but you know what that simple
note that she gave us enabled us to go
from 3 hours 15 to 2 hours 48 and it
just made the thing snap oh yeah oh yeah
big deal reason number 9 they don't have
a competitive advantage with Warren
Buffett the nature of capitalism is that
people want to come in and take your
capsules perfectly understandable I mean
if I'm solving television sets or
something there's going to be 10 other
people who are gonna try and sell a
better television set if I have a
restaurant here in Omaha people are
gonna try and copy my menu and get more
parking and take my chef and so on so
capitalism is all about somebody coming
and trying to take the castle now what
you need is you need a castle that has
some durable competitive advantage some
castle that has a moat around and that
moat that's one of the best moats in
many respects is to be a low-cost
producer but sometimes the motors just
having more talent I mean if you're the
heavyweight champion of the world and
keep knocking out people you've got a
competitive advantage as long as you can
keep doing it and it's very profitable
if you're the one that happens to be
able to do it if you can turn out great
motion picture
I mean you know Steven Spielberg I mean
he he he's a fella Tibet on and and it
has an enormous economic value and
recent number ten the last step before
very special Elon Musk bonus clip I
think you're gonna enjoy number ten is
they give up with Tony Robbins there is
another level the only reason you keep
seeing there isn't as you feel so
exhausted about where you are but life
the universe or God is just testing you
because there is another level if this
is good
giant jump to excellence Giants start a
good poor to good to excellence there's
a level where all your dreams are
realized there's a level that you've
always dreamed about it is real it has
not gone away but it takes that extra
burst when you think there's nothing
left there's no way you've tried
everything ten million times and you
keep going it's almost like God is
saying if you keep hitting this wall
enough times I will see that you will
not stop that you were filled with that
level of determination of faith and
courage and then the door opens and you
get to that next level but most people
don't know is the next level is just two
millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding what's it called what's it
called what's it called outstanding
magnificent unstoppable extraordinary
not excellent it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know
what's amazing you only have to be two
million is more than everybody else and
you get everything you get the joy the
last day the fun in the family the
passion the economics the freedom the
spirit it's all there what Jerry Maguire
called the Quan baby all of it and it's
just two million years above and most
excellent people give up because they're
exhausted and there's some people go the
harder I hit it the more I hit it sooner
or later it's going down I'm not
stopping and when you do that enough it
pops open
now I've got a very special clip with
Elon Musk on how to act
despite being afraid that I think you're
really going to enjoy but before that I
want you to make a commitment of the day
you watch this video you took the time
to consume the content now do something
about it what is your commitment that
you will change today leave it down in
the comments below I'm really excited to
find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
you are unusually fearless and willing
to go in the face of other people
telling you something that's crazy
and I know a lot of pretty crazy people
you still stand out where does that come
from or how do you think about making a
decision when everyone tells you this is
a crazy idea where do you get the
internal strength to do that
well office well I'd say I actually
think I feel feel fear quite strongly so
it's not as though I just have the
absence of fear I've I feel it quite
strongly but there were times when
something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do you do it
in spite of the fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think III I should if
you should think well I feel fear about
this and therefore I shouldn't do it
it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong you shouldn't feel fear
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway
yeah you know actually we're something
that can be helpful as fatalism some
degree if you just think if just accept
the probabilities then that diminishes
fear so we're starting SpaceX I thought
the odds of success were less than 10%
and I just accepted that actually
probably I would just lose lose
everything but that maybe would make
some progress if we could just move the
ball forward even if we died maybe some
other company could pick up the baton
and move and keep moving it forward so
that we still do some good yeah same
with Tesla I thought your odds of a car
company succeeding were extremely love
[Music]
or ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be to like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]